vas-y a présenté sa première console
c'est la Rogue à l'ail c'est la première
fois qu'il vient s'ouvrir au niveau du
marché de la console de gaming c'est une
console qui est pas trop lourde 608 g
toute la finition plastique on va
retrouver un écran de 7 pouces c'est du
LCD résolution 1080p avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va aller jusqu'à
120 et un temps de réponse de 7
millisecondes qui dit Asus et console
portative on se doit d'avoir de la
puissance là-dessous et bien vous avez
une puce de AMD c'est une ryzen Z1 mais
également la Z1 extrême côté graphique
c'est la MDRD na3 on va voir ici 16 Go
oh pdr5 et 512 Go de stockage avec un
stockage extensible en micro SD d'un
point de vue ergonomique je trouve qu'on
a un très bon accès au bouton vous avez
également les gâchettes derrière bref
c'est très pratique très facile à
utiliser une console vous me direz c'est
bien mais qu'est-ce qu'on va voir comme
jeu dessus et bien beaucoup d'expérience
au niveau du cloud gaming steam Epic
Games Xbox game pass d'ailleurs vous
avez trois mois offert au Xbox game pass
à l'achat de la console alors pour
l'instant le tarif n'est pas encore
donné mais je vous en parlerai très
bientôt sur YouTube sur mon test complet
donc pensez bien vous abonner puis
surtout dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez marquez moi ça bien évidemment
dans les commentaires